- Call this a tough life?
This is nothing. You're wet, enjoy it!
- I'm not enjoying being wet all over!
- I married a minion.
- I'm not a minion.
I'm not that yellow.
- We all got soaked!
Look at Nina's hair!
How you guys doing?
- Look at my shoes!
- Is this cool, guys?
- Yes!
- This is the coolest thing ever.
- Yeah, I'm hot.
- I know you are.
But what am I?
- You're . .
- I'm hot, too. Yeah.
- That was cool. It's totally worth it.
You guys go here, you
got to go check it out.
It's really, really fun.
(whooshing air)
(gun shot)
(glass shatters)
(chimes)
- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today is day?
- Seven.
- We're going to?
- Universal Studios!
- Home!
- I'm excited. I don't
know if anyone else..
- I'm excited!
- Evan is stressed out.
- I am?
Yes, I'm very stressed out.
I don't know. How do I act stressed out?
(grumbles)
(laughter)
Good morning! We're excited.
First time any of us have
been to Universal Studios
so it's a new adventure for all of us.
We're doing it because
the kids want to see Harry Potter stuff.
- And we hate Animal Kingdom.
- It's really just
learning about everything.
- And they don't like Animal Kingdom.
So maybe next year, we'll
take one day less vacation
but for this year, we're going to go to
I was going to say, we're
going to go to Animal Kingdom,
We're going to go to Universal
and we're headed there now.
Here we go!
(cheers)
(upbeat music)
- We're making our way.
First stop is going to
be the crazy worm face!
It's not true.
First stop is Starbucks for Nina!
Look at the happy smile.
What do you think, Nina?
- Yes.
- Happy? Happy?
- Is that a play area?
- It's a golf course. It's mini golf.
You want to go mini golfing?
- No.
- Yes.
- We'll spend the whole day mini golfing
instead of Universal.
- No!
- Because Jeffrey wants to.
- No? Okay.
- Starbuck's first then, for Nina.
Nina looks excited.
Kind of.
That's as much excitement as you get
from Nina in the morning.
(upbeat music)
- Shorter lines. Shorter
lines than Disney.
I like it.
And?
Instantly better.
- It's very strong.
- All right, guys. First up?
Harry Potter, Forbidden Journey!
- Oh! What's that?
- We're going on a Harry Potter ride.
- Oh, okay.
- Wow! The excitement is real.
(majestic music)
- This is so cool!
- Is this cool, guys?
- Yes!
- This is the coolest thing ever.
- Whoa, there's the castle!
- Wow!
- Oh my gosh!
- That is just unreal.
- That is so, so cool.
- We're going to go in
there. Are you ready?
- Yes!
- What? We're going in?
- I think so.
- Yay!
- I'm freaking out here!
- You're freaking out?
- Oh, there's the ride and the hippogriff!
- Yeah, you're ready? We're
going inside the castle.
There it is!
- I'm not allowed to bring anything in
so I got to put everything in
a locker including the camera.
So, see you guys on the other side.
What did we think, mister?
Thumbs up.
How was it?
- Scary.
- Nina was scared.
- I was scared.
- I closed my eyes only
when it's a bad part.
- That was cool. It's totally worth it.
You guys go here, you
got to go check it out.
It's really, really fun.
Next up, Flight of the Hippogriff!
We're going on this.
You ready?
Let's do it.
(peppy music)
- These guys are cheap here.
Don't let you film anything.
- I know.
- Don't let you film
anything, but how was it?
- It was good.
- Awesome!
- Hayden.
Hayden had fun.
It was fast. It was pretty cool.
I was tempted to pull out the
camera anyway. You know me.
- It was like The Great Goofini.
- What?
- Great Goofini, but faster. Faster.
Next up, we're going to go to King Kong!
- That one's a scary one.
- King Kong!
Once again, no photography
or video recording.
(boos)
Universal Studios.
We're done. The effects are pretty cool.
Some pretty, pretty cool effects.
It's too bad we're not allowed
to film anything inside.
Maybe a little scary for the kids.
How you doing?
Happy? Thumbs down.
Hayden was scared, but it was good.
- Good, but scary.
- Good? Nina?
- Yes.
- The effects are pretty amazing, eh?
- Yeah.
- Pretty amazing effects.
Hayden was not happy.
They killed these giant bugs
and it sprayed water all over us.
It was pretty fun.
Okay, kids. Next up, Spiderman!
Spiderman! Let's go.
Something tells me they're
not going to let me film
in Spiderman so I'll take
some B-roll on my way there
so you guys can at least
get a sense of the park.
(upbeat music)
It's pretty cool, man. It's
pretty cool inside these.
They do a really good job.
How was it?
- So nasty!
- Oh no. Hayden's not in a great mood.
But it was pretty cool.
What did we think, guys?
- Good.
- Nina?
- Yeah, it was good.
- Scary?
- No, it's not scary,
but actually quite fun.
- Fun. Good.
All right, next up, we're
going on some water rides!
Water rides.
- Are we going on the
one that we saw before
that I said it was so fun?
- I think so.
- Now?
- I don't know. Are you excited?
- I guess.
- Nina's excited to go on water rides.
- Yeah. Very excited.
- She needs to cool off.
- Yeah, I'm hot.
- I know you are, but what am I?
I'm hot, too. Yeah.
(downtempo music)
We're going to go on this!
- Right now?
- Yup!
- That was the one that we said yes to.
- Yeah. Let's go here.
- Yay!
- Oh, now you're excited?
- Yeah!
- All right.
All right, time to put the camera away.
Don't want it getting wet.
Here we go!
We all got soaked!
Look at Nina's hair! How you guys doing?
- Look at my shoes!
Look at my shoes!
- Least I wore a hat.
Didn't mess up my hair.
Nina's taking water out of her
pants. How you doing, Nina?
- It's cold.
- It's freezing.
(water splash)
Everything is soaked.
Here they come! The soaked party.
- Look at my shoes! They
literally turned gray.
- Yeah, I see it.
- Nina's hair is amazing. Whoo!
We're not going to go
on the waterfall one.
Kids can't handle a little bit of wet.
- We're soaked!
- I'm all wet.
- You call this a little
bit? We're soaked!
- You call this a tough
life? This is nothing.
You're wet, enjoy it.
- I'm not enjoying being wet all over!
- Such a complainer. This is nothing.
Try being an entrepreneur, guys.
Try opening your own business.
You think this is a rough life?
- Yup!
- You don't know pain.
You don't know pain.
Start your own company, that's pain.
This is nothing.
- We're not going on the waterfall.
- All right, no waterfall rides.
These kids need to toughen up.
Toughen up. Right?
What do you guys think?
How you doing, Nina?
- It's wet.
- It's wet, but we don't
complain in this family, right?
Boom!
Okay, I'll have to figure
where we're going next.
It's not going to be the waterfall ride.
(cheerful music)
This is the ride we are not goin on.
Who wants to go on that?
- You.
- Who wants to go on that?
- Evan!
- Guys, it's just water.
All right, let's keep going!
Another ride the kids don't want to go on
because they might get a little bit wet.
Look! Nobody's soaked in their hair.
What do you think? Are we going to do it?
- I'm not doing it.
- We're going to go? Hayden wants to go?
- Nina?
- You don't get wet, Nina.
- I'm not doing it.
- Jeffrey? Jeffery wants to go?
Nina?
- Stephanie doesn't want to.
- All right, the boys want to do it!
(cheers)
- I'm sitting in the middle.
- You'll sit in the middle.
Okay, there's the thing
and I got to put the camera away again.
See you guys soon.
How was it, guys?
- So awesome!
- How was it, Jeffrey?
- Awesome.
- We have to go on that
next year. Have to.
- I like the excitement.
All right, let's get out.
(downtempo music)
It's time to go eat at the
Harry Potter restaurant
and get our wands.
(cheers)
Let's go.
All right, it's lunch time.
We got fish 'n' chips and
shepherd's pie and fish 'n' chips.
- I don't like shepherd's pie.
- That's why you have fish 'n' chips.
In the Harry Potter themed restaurant.
Look at the glasses. See what it says?
- The Wizarding World of Harry Potter.
- Pretty cool, eh?
(mellow music)
How is it?
- Good.
- Yummy? All right.
It is time to? What's it time to?
What's it time to?
- Huh?
- What's it time to? What are we doing?
- Wands!
- Buy some magic wands.
Let's go.
So, every year we have this
policy that the kids get
to pick one thing as a present
and they have to like it
and not ask every time we go in the store.
And they all decided, in
advance, that they wanted to buy
a magic wand at the Ollivanders Wand Shop.
So, we saved it for the last day
and we're about to go buy them right now.
I think it's like 50 bucks a wand
or something but it's all good.
Let's do it. It's for the kids.
(classical music)
Time to buy some wands.
Who's is that?
- Death Eater's but it
doesn't say which Death Eater.
- Isn't this the gold label?
- Yeah. I think so.
You got a Death Eater's wand?
- Yeah.
- That's what you wanted? Are you happy?
All right.
- I got the map so I'll put it in my bag.
I got the map.
- Let's see you cast a spell.
Whoa!
- Oh, I did it again!
- How's the wife doing?
You okay? Tired?
- Kind of.
- Wants some caffeine?
- No.
- No? Want some water?
- Maybe.
- Oh, you want water? We'll get water.
We're going to be leaving
this side of Universal Studios,
hopping on Hogwarts Express
and going to London,
the other side.
(classical music)
All right, once again,
not allowed to film.
Good job, Universal Studios.
But we made it into London and
we're going to have more fun.
(light music)
Ready? Through the wall, ready?
Diagon Alley.
- Oh my.
This is seriously unreal.
- Pretty unreal?
(light music)
We're going to lose our bags
again. No filming again.
It's quite an experience, but no filming.
Takes a little bit out of it.
I want to share with you guys.
But we'll go have some fun, at least.
Well, another really fun ride.
Universal does a good job.
- Yeah.
- Nina screamed the whole time
and almost fell out of her chair.
- How do you know?
- Because you were behind me.
I can't hear you on this side anymore.
- Yeah.
- Was it fun?
- Yes.
- Yeah? All right. Good.
Let's keep it moving. More rides to come.
(cheerful music)
Next up, Men in Black.
- What's Men in Black?
- It's a ride. The Men in Black ride.
Let's do it.
(upbeat music)
Hey-hey! Guess what? No cameras again.
Yeah, Universal Studios.
So, to go on the ride,
you got to put your stuff
in these lockers so you
got to squish everything in
and then there's massive
line-ups to get your stuff back.
Which is a big pain in the butt.
So, I think when we come back,
we either don't bring
bags or don't come back.
Universal, dude, you
got to do a better job.
(upbeat music)
Next ride up is The Simpsons ride.
- Yay!
- Simpsons ride.
- What'd you think?
Thumbs up?
I'm nauseous.
- You're nauseous?
- How you doing?
- I'm good.
- You're okay? How you guys doing?
- Fun.
- Nauseous. Simulation rides.
- What ride are we going on next?
- I don't know. We'll see.
(uptempo music)
All right, kids. Next
up, The Minions ride!
(cheers)
Let's see some minions.
I married a minion.
- I'm not a minion.
I'm not that yellow.
- She likes banana.
- I do like banana.
- Nina, what did you
have for breakfast today?
- Two bananas.
See! I married a minion.
All right, so it's
another motion simulator.
The last one made me nauseous so
I'm going to sit this one out.
Let the kids and Nina have fun
and just take in some
sun, in beautiful Florida.
(cheerful music)
How was it?
- Awesome!
- It was awesome.
- Was it good?
- Yeah, it was.
- You enjoyed?
- Yes.
- Would I have enjoyed? Probably not.
- No, it's not that bad, actually.
- Last thing of the day, then we go home.
We're going to get ice
cream, then we go home.
Shrek in 4D!
You ready?
The excitement is unreal.
Shrek 4D. Here we go.
- Daddy!
- How was it?
- Good!
- Good?
- Time for ice cream!
- Ice cream.
Ice cream.
(warm music)
All right, kids are having ice
cream. Nina got a huge one.
How's the ice cream, kids?
- It's good.
- I have little bits of cotton candy.
- You got cotton candy? It's yummy.
- Me too.
- He got cotton candy.
- Stephanie got Milk and Cookies, I think.
Nina got the ginormous Chocolate Chunk.
- Triple Caramel Chocolate Chunk.
- And there's mine. Milk shake.
- Is it good?
- Mm-hmm. Chocolatey. Want to try it?
- Yeah.
Yeah, very chocolatey.
- All right, that's it for us today.
Thank you, guys, for joining
us. Hope you enjoyed.
You guys have fun?
- Yes!
- Favorite ride of the day?
- Minions.
- Minions? Wow! More than
the Harry Potter stuff.
- Oh, Harry Potter!
- The wand! The wand thing.
- The wand. Nina?
- The wand!
- Ice cream.
- Ice cream. Wow!
Next time, we'll just get
you ice cream, you stay home.
There's Ben & Jerry's everywhere.
Thank you, guys, for watching!
Continue to believe!
- We'll see you soon.
Whatever you want, we're in.
- Bye, guys.
Nina can do whatever she wants because?
- I'm Nina.
- She's Nina Carmichael.
That's how we roll.
(whooshing air)